[Musique]
la finlande vient de défier son voisin
russe c'est une grande première la
guerre russes contre l'ukraine est un
tournant pour l'europe entière et cela a
profondément changé l'environnement
sécuritaire européen tout comme notre
perception de la russie la confiance est
perdue pour des générations quelques
jours après la demande d'adhésion à
l'otan la première ministre finlandaise
enfonce le clou la confiance est perdue
une petite phrase qui enterre près de 75
ans de relation de neutralité avec
moscou
la finlande est neutre mais d'une
neutralité qu'il ressemble à aucune
depuis 1948 et la signature d'un traité
d'amitié et de coopération avec la
russie l'un finlande avait la garantie
de rester libre et souveraine une
sécurité à quel prix une neutralité
imposer certains politologues parle même
de vassalisation mais le concept va
avoir un nom la finlandisation et selon
les finlandais leur position
géographique ne leur permettait pas
d'autre choix je suis pour la neutralité
de la finlande évidemment on ne se sent
pas vraiment en sécurité à côté d'un
puissant voisin à la chute de l'urss la
finlande respire un peu elle affiche sa
volonté d'intégrer l'union européenne
une mauvaise idée pour certains synonyme
de provocation à l'égard du géant russe
pour la finlande cela ne vaut pas le
coup de s'engager dans une union qui
s'opposerait à la russie parce que dans
toute cette région il y a beaucoup de
nucléaire si jamais on adhérer à l'union
européenne ou à l'otan la finlande
deviendrait une cible facile la
meilleure chose que l'on puisse faire
c'est de ne dépendre de personne pour
notre sécurité
malgré la réticence d'une partie de la
population en 1995 la finlande rejoint
l'union européenne était lé premier
discours le voisin russe n'est pas
oubliée il ne faudrait pas le vexer
une société stable développer sans
problème nos ressources naturelles et
une tradition de coopération avec la
russie et les pays baltes voilà ce que
nous allons apporter alors
mais quand en 2016 la finlande laisse
entendre qu'elle pourrait rejoindre
l'otan vladimir poutine menace d'une
attaque lancée vous que nous allons
continuer ainsi
que nous garderons notre pas 1500
kilomètres de la frontière
pour paraphraser les paroles d'un ami
finlandais
je dirais que l'otan serait probablement
ravis de faire la guerre à la russie
jusqu'au dernier soldat finlandaise est
ce que c'est vraiment ce que vous voulez
malgré ces menaces l'invasion en ukraine
a été l'élément déclencheur
la finlande a rompu avec sa neutralité
en soutenant kiev et en affichant sa
volonté de rejoindre l'otan
[Musique]